Venezuela descends into further chaos as
people starve and tanks crush protesters
but socialists in the united states like
bernie sanders and alexandria Ocasio
cortez refused to admit that venezuela
is their utopia the logical conclusion
of their awful ideas we will examine how
socialism ruined that country and others
then Democrat senators try and fail to
grill Attorney General William bar over
the Muller report we'll check in on that
finally academics in Great Britain
declare pedophilia normal and natural
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
this is going to be a very abnormal and
unnatural show discussing all of those
things we'll get to them in a second
first there's a lot of things in life
that aren't right that aren't normal
that aren't natural carpet in showers
eating dip with your fingers chunky
style milk and paying too much for your
phone bill that is not right that is
wrong but thanks to Mint mobile you
don't have to overpay for wireless
anymore
mint mobile has completely changed the
game you can cut your wireless bill down
to just 15 bucks a month now you might
have heard these kind of things oh you
can cut your bill in half and then it
lasts for two seconds and then your bill
goes up to $200 again not with mint
mobile they have reimagined Wireless
they've made it easy and online-only it
means they can pass significant savings
directly to you you can save literally
thousands of dollars a year using mint
mobile without sacrificing quality
service mint mobile makes it easy to cut
your wireless bill down to 15 bucks a
month I know what you're that you're
hearing that you're saying 15 plus
another 60 for fees and another 120 for
taxes and none of this no use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan keep
your old number all your old contacts
with mint mobile you choose between
three eight and twelve gigabyte plans of
4G LTE data you stop paying for
unlimited data that you'll never use
that's how big Wireless raises your
right to a zillion dollars don't don't
do it every plane comes with unlimited
nationwide talking text if you're not
100% satisfied mid mobile has a 7 day
money-back guarantee ditch your old bill
start saving with mint mode will get
your new wireless plan for 15 bucks a
month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mint mobile comm
slash Knowles cane or wles that's mint
mobile.com slash Knowles cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month get
free shipping on your mint mobile plan
mint mobile comm slash Knolls other
things that are abnormal and unnatural
are happening in Venezuela right now
this clip just came out yesterday
rightly horrified the world a tank a
government tank pull that under the
street and crushed starving protesters
in Venezuela military truck rammed into
a group of
testers and katanas just one of several
violent clashes between security forces
and thousands of anti-government
protesters this has been going on for
weeks and weeks and months and months
now why is it going on because of
socialism this is socialism the tanks
running over the protesters is socialism
this is the logical conclusion of
socialism it was ever thus this is the
conclusion of what Alexandria Ocasio
cortes and Bernie Sanders are offering
not tomorrow not the next week not the
week after that luckily America has a
strong culture and economic and
political heritage of freedom so it's
not as though Bernie Sanders would get
elected and then the next day you'd have
tanks running over people in the street
but given enough time and given enough
success at implementing the agenda that
they are proposing the tanks crushing
the people in the streets is the logical
conclusion what does socialism look like
looks like violent clashes in the
streets in Venezuela
looks like the opposition leader down
there Juan Guido calling on the military
to overturn the government there the
Maduro regime it looks like CNN now
being taken off of the airwaves by the
government which is proof positive that
every storm cloud has a silver lining
not everything is bad down there but
most things are very bad doctors have
injured or rather are treating 50
injured people right now just from those
clashes yesterday that includes a woman
who is shot in the abdomen there's a
gunfire obviously the tanks Amnesty
International is reporting systemic
oppression throughout that country and
for a long time now extrajudicial
executions so the Maduro regime will go
in in the middle of the night will drag
people out who they think are a threat
to their political stability - or to
their political power they will take
them out and they will kill them with
that any law without any trial without
any due process just kill them one third
of Venezuelans are estimated according
to Amnesty International
to eat one meal per day many Venezuelans
go multiple days without eating in fact
there there were interviews among the
Miami Herald and other newspapers that
talked to some of these Venezuelans and
they will say they will just wait with
hundreds and hundreds of people in bread
lines at their churches to hope to get
one meal every couple days in that bread
lines that's socialism for you
inflation as a result of the government
not cutting spending of the government
printing money of the government
over-promising and under-delivering
inflation in Venezuela Gino high it's
gone right now I think inflation well in
in the 1980s I think inflation in
Venezuela hit about 80 percent that's a
very high 80 percent inflation is a big
deal those were the good old days
compared to now right now inflation is
about 1.3 million percent in Venezuela
the currency is worth nothing in January
inflation rose up to about 2.7 million
percent that's the conclusion of
socialism
how did this happen people forget now
because we have short historical
memories we forget that Venezuela was a
very rich country for most of the 20th
century Venezuela wasn't the richest
country in South America now it had
periods of economic difficulties that in
the 1980s there was a huge spike in
inflation not huge compared to today but
still it was significant why did those
happen well one Venezuela is largely
dependent on oil prices so fluctuations
in oil prices do affect the country also
because when all that oil money started
pouring in politicians and the
government decided they could start
buying off votes through socialism now
at a certain point in the 1990s you saw
GDP declining
you saw inflation increasing then when
the governments would decide to cut back
on socialism start liberalizing the
economies start allowing more free
markets in all of a sudden you saw GDP
start to increase again you saw
inflation start to curb again you saw
wages even rise then Hugo Chavez took
over the
socialist politician Hugo Chavez
campaigned and took power officially in
1999 I'm actually old enough to remember
when this happened and I remember all
the left wingers loved Hugo Chavez he
was on the American media all the time
I've I've been in news hands since I was
like 2 years old and I remember Hugo
Chavez was the big hope of all the
leftists it was always on the mainstream
media that guy Sean Penn the famous
actor loved Hugo Chavez go down there
all of these people so happy socialism
has come to Venezuela Hugo Chavez died
in 2013 as the economy collapsed as
finally that poison ran its course now
you see the results this is the result
of Hugo Chavez this is the result of
socialism why how did it happen so
Chavez when he came to power in 1999
relied on these massive oil revenues
that he was getting to increase public
spending and buy votes so he would take
all of this money and then he would buy
foreign food it's not as though he was
cultivating new new industries or
cultivating the economy he would just
use it to buy foreign food and then
subsidize that food for the people so
he's basically buying off the people
with cheap food then as a result of this
plan the foreign debt of Venezuela
quadrupled just under Chavez's reign so
debt is mounting the economy is
beginning to falter what does Chavez do
does he cut back public spending no of
course not does he curb socialism no of
course not what he does is he seizes
even more political power so at this
point the only way like any Ponzi scheme
the only way to keep this going is to
take more and more stuff so Hugo Chavez
decided to nationalize companies and
farms and factories now nationalize is a
really fancy leftist term that means
steel so his regime stole whole
companies whole farms from people full
factories as a result of this by the way
ExxonMobil and ConocoPhillips left the
country of Venezuela so now you've got
international capital is pulling out
because they can't be in this unstable
region
where this thug government is just going
to steal your property so they start
pulling out the economy continues to
falter so what does Shabbos do does he
pull back on socialism of course not
he seizes even more political power in
2012 not long before he died he outlawed
private gun ownership all throughout
Venezuela let me tell you something if
those people who were being crushed by
tanks right now had private gun
ownership they would not be being
crushed by tanks because they would be
shooting the military and the cops and
the thugs who are oppressing them and
who are attacking them and who were
killing them extra judicially now this
brings us to 2013 Chavez dies Maduro his
hand-picked successor takes power at
this point I actually almost feel bad
for Maduro because the poison of
socialism had run its course so there
was very little that he could do the the
bill for all that free stuff that Hugo
Chavez was giving out finally came due
and at the same time a drop in oil
prices meant that the government
couldn't even keep up the pretense of
solvency the jig was up so the one thing
Maduro could have done is he could have
gradually cut spending he could have
shown that he was gradually willing to
respect property rights he was eager for
foreign investment he was going to deal
responsibly with his government and then
maybe more money would have come in is
that what he did no of course not
because he's a socialist so instead what
he did is he just started printing money
I love when politicians think they can
just print more money they this has
never worked in all of history it's not
even really a short term solution
because the minute you start doing it
everybody begins to distrust your
government distrust your economy and
very very quickly you get hyperinflation
which is exactly what happened the
hyperinflation triggered this revolution
because the money was worthless and that
revolution triggered the violent
crackdown that you see from the
government that you see from tanks
rolling over citizens in Venezuela this
is not the first time this has happened
at a socialist government this always
happens in socialist governments this
always
happened in the Soviet Union it happened
obviously in North Korea it happened in
other Latin American socialist
governments happened in China happened
in all of these places this is socialism
and here's the scary number according to
Gallup polling the majority of young
Americans support socialism they look
favorably on socialism and according to
that same poll only 45% of young
Americans look favorably on capitalism
which is to say private property which
is to say the free exchange of goods and
services young America is far more
socialist than capitalist the good news
is a lot of polls show that young
Americans can't define socialism that's
a good thing but why do they identify as
socialist why do they look upon it
favorably it's because politicians like
Bernie Sanders and Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez are openly peddling this
poisonous ideology and what they say is
our idea of socialism
it's like Iceland it's like Denmark
it's like Sweden it's not like Venezuela
no no no don't don't look at Venezuela
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain
no no look over here at the Nordic
countries that is simply a lie we will
explain why it's a lie in a second but
first Lending Club if you are carrying
revolving debt that means that you're
not paying off your credit card every
month and you could be paying thousands
in interest every year that you don't
have to with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment if
certain nations consolidated their debt
and started to pay it off responsibly
you wouldn't see chaos around the world
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to
the bank no high interest credit cards
just go to Lending Club com tell them
about yourself and how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
thirty five billion dollars in loans
issued don't end up like the government
of Venezuela go to Lending Club
/ Knowles Cana wles check your rate in
minutes and borrow up to $40,000 Lending
Club dot-com / Knowles Keo wles that is
Lending Club calm / Knowles KO wles
all loans made by web bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender Bernier OC they
want to tell you that the socialism that
they're pushing is like the Nordic
countries it's not like Venezuela not a
lie the Nordic countries have relatively
free economies they have no minimum wage
none of those countries has a minimum
wage Sweden has a universal school
choice if a farm more free market
approach to education than even the
United States has Iceland has a freer
economy than the United States according
to the Heritage Foundation index for
economic freedom if a OC wants to be
more like Iceland than she ought to
support freeing up the economy not
increased socialism the danish prime
minister former Danish Prime Minister
Lars Rasmussen puts the point very
clearly he says quote Denmark is far
from a socialist planned economy Denmark
is a market economy but what a OC and
Bernie Sanders are pushing is a
socialist planned economy and you know
the it's so disingenuous if you hear
Bernie Sanders or ASU talk about this
Bernie Sanders didn't have his honeymoon
in Denmark he didn't go on his honeymoon
to Iceland he went on his honeymoon in
1988 the day after he got married to the
Soviet Union
in fact I'm sorry to say we have video
of this of Bernie Sanders shirtless
drinking vodka
singing commie songs with the Russkies
in the Soviet Union in 1988
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna rewrite it I'm gonna do a
version of it which is this land is my
land this land is my land this lands not
your land this land is my land that's
gonna be the song that I sing at the
southern border but that'll be for a
later show don't worry about that now
Bernie Sanders was so enthralled with
the Soviet Union with Soviet Communism
the most repressive regime on earth one
of the most repressive regime regimes in
the history of the world
that he took his honeymoon there didn't
want to go to Scandinavia wanted to go
there
worse even than Venezuela and just to
remind you that he's not pushing
policies that would bring us to Iceland
he's pushing the policies of Latin
America it ran that same time three
years earlier 1985 Bernie Sanders was
defending socialist breadlines in Latin
America 20 sometimes American
journalists talk about how bad the
country is because people are lining up
the food that's a good thing in other
countries people don't line up food the
rich get the food and the poor starve to
death
bread lines are a good thing bread lines
are a good thing in a lot of countries
the rich get food and the poor starve to
death right in socialist countries
that's what happens that's what's
happening in Venezuela right now and if
they don't starve to death they get run
over by tanks that doesn't happen in the
United States
nobody starves to death in the United
States the biggest problem afflicting
the poor in the United States is obesity
the problem among the poor in the United
States is that they're eating too much
that's not what happens in socialist
countries they starve to death well the
rich and the well-connected in the
cronies all benefit make no mistake the
policies that they are pushing or
they're they're not just leading us to
the road on the road to Venezuela they
are even radical by that standard just
the green New Deal just the green New
Deal one policy that they're pushing
co-sponsors aoc wrote it herself is a
full government takeover of huge swaths
of the economy all of the health care
radical socialist healthcare regime then
an outline of about 90% of the American
energy industry then a federal job
guarantee program you get rid of parts
of the welfare state and now you just
have to work for the government then an
outlawing of planes trains and
automobiles so you don't get to keep
your car then an outlying of your home
an outlying of all of the current
buildings in the United States because
according to the green new deal which
Bernie co-sponsors which they OC wrote
we need to knock down every building in
the country and rebuild it within ten
years as we eliminate 90% of the
American energy industry you can't even
keep your own home that's the kind of
takeover that we're talking about that's
what they're pushing that's not Denmark
that's not Iceland
that's not Sweden that is Venezuela
that's worse than Venezuela America is a
richer country America is a bigger
country America has better institutions
America has a longer tradition of
Liberty okay Venezuela was a rich
country Venezuela was a prosperous
country was the most prosperous country
in the region and eventually steadily
gradually socialism ruined it now there
are tanks crushing citizens in the
street why does the Left get away with
this how do we let the left get away
with this part of why we've got to call
out Bernie Sanders and AOC here is that
the American left never apologized for
its support of the Soviet Union you had
reporters in the New York Times and
other newspapers in in the early days of
the Soviet Union saying I've seen the
future and it works you had reporters in
those early days denying the Holodomor
denying famines caused by Stalin
denying all of the atrocities being
committed by Stalin lying about it
because they were so committed to the
Communist cause in fact the conservative
movement as we know it was founded
because of those early reports about the
Soviet Union when you had American
newspapers publishing about the Soviet
Union I've seen the future and it works
you then had William F Buckley Jr start
the flagship conservative newspaper
National Review or magazine rather with
in the first issue with the thesis a
conservative is one who stands a fort
history yelling stop the Communists see
the future and it works and the
Conservatives are there saying stop it
doesn't work it's not gonna work it's
it's evil even if it did work but what
does it mean to even work who care let's
say that socialism actually did work
which it doesn't let's say socialism
created a lot of economic prosperity and
everybody had a lot of material goods
but it robbed you of all of your Liberty
it robbed you of all of your
institutions your civic institutions it
exerted so much power of the federal
government over you that your way of
life your culture your traditions were
totally crushed who cares how materially
prosperous you are even if socialism
worked it would be evil
but it also doesn't work it also leads
to widespread misery the American Left
can admit that they never apologized for
the Soviet Union they never apologized
for their support of Fidel Castro oh the
left loved Fidel Castro they brought him
to the United Nations in New York oh
they love they sometimes wear his face
on t-shirts they wear Che Guevara 's
face on t shirts even today never
apologized for that these people
enslaved an entire country in Cuba and
American liberals wear their faces on
shirts like there are Disney characters
they never apologized for their support
of Hugo Chavez go talk to Sean Penn go
talk to all the Hollywood leftists who
loved Hugo Chavez go talk to all the
activists who loved Hugo Chavez no
apology they can't ever admit the
logical conclude
their ideas it's happened time and time
again Soviet Union China Cuba all around
Latin America now Venezuela they can't
no no that was wrong
socialism that was fake socialism next
time it will work just give it one more
try no more tries certainly not in the
United States
speaking of incoherent leftism and a
good way to smack it down we can switch
gears over to Attorney General William
Barr testifying on the hill today before
the Senate Judiciary Committee he's
being called to testify over the Muller
report now the Democrats are calling on
attorney general Barr to resign
what's the big takeaway here the big
takeaway is since the Muller report was
released Democrats have nothing they've
got nothing they bet the farm on this
Russia collusion thing two years more
than two years they bet everything on it
and it didn't happen it didn't pan out
you had Eric's wall well presidential
candidates saying Trump is a traitor we
know that he colluded with the Russians
didn't happen and so now what are they
doing there they're grasping at straws
now they want to impeach William Bar for
some reason the new Attorney General so
that I guess we'll get a new Attorney
General and then the one on Peacham to
the other big takeaway from this hearing
today is that it's all theater it is all
theater this is why I didn't lead with
this story if you tuned in to CNN right
now this is the biggest story on the top
of the page and you've got to pay
attention it doesn't really matter in
terms of the Department of Justice in
terms of the Russia investigation in
terms of the Trump administration
doesn't really matter what it matters
for is to show you the desperation of
Democrats in the Senate it's a story
that people are talking about but it's a
story that matters only in so much as
it's a bunch of hot air it's important
as political theater we have the Muller
report you can read the report I've read
the relevant sections of it probably
hundred fifty two hundred pages of it
that's enough that's
you need to read you can see no
collusion no obstruction the report left
open the question of obstruction most
legal scholars and certainly the legal
scholars that we talked to Alan
Dershowitz those kind of people say even
leaving open the question of obstruction
was pretty absurd even the framework of
obstruction that Bob Miller was working
with is pretty absurd but regardless
it's up to the Department of Justice to
determine whether or not obstruction
occurred the Attorney General says it
didn't occur the Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein who is certainly no
conservative Republican
he said no obstruction occurred no no
indictments no nothing so now we're
arguing over the summaries and the press
reports and the phone calls in the leaks
and this why are we arguing over any of
that we have the report itself you can
read the report the report exonerates
President Trump but they just can't let
it go because they bet their whole two
years on it
so now they're trying to rehash anything
around the edges of the report so the
left needs a new boogeyman filling that
role we now have Attorney General
William bar they want him to be
impeached and they say he lied to
Congress that's the basis for them
calling for his impeachment okay let's
take them at their word they're saying
he lied to Congress what did he lie
about they're saying that the last time
he appeared before Congress he lied when
he was asked the question of whether or
not Bob Muller agrees with his
conclusions about the Muller report and
here was William bars answer Bob
Mahler's support your conclusion I don't
know whether Bob dollar supported my
conclusions
okay he's asked the question does Bob
Muller support your conclusions what
William bar I think wanted to say is I
don't care if Bob Muller supports my
conclusions Bob Muller is not the
Attorney General and I am what he says
is I don't know if he supports the
conclusions now the Democrats are saying
that was a lie what is their evidence
that that was a lie a letter from Bob
Muller
- William bar leaked coincidentally by
the way it leaked the night before we
barré testifies before the senate yeah
what a coincidence that's so strange I
wonder who could have leaked that letter
that was written by the Muller team two
people have that letter Muller and bar
I don't think bar League did so somebody
associated with Bob Muller leaked that
letter okay
very saying this is evidence that
William bar lied to Congress but what
does the letter actually say does the
letter show that Muller thinks that bars
conclusions were wrong or he disagrees
or he agrees or the bar lied to Congress
will read the actual letter in a second
but first we've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube go over to Daly
wire.com ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Andrew Klavan show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Mount Walt show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
coming up tomorrow get the min you get
to watch backstage ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom
podcast and you get this the leftist
tears tumblr we're about to get into
some of that Democrat questioning of
William Bar we're about to watch how
William bar has a higher IQ than every
Democrat member of this committee
combined and you are going to need the
tumbler or else you are going to drown
go to daily wire.com we'll be right back
what does the letter actually say
Democrats think that this letter from
Muller Tabar is evidence that Barre lied
to Congress and that Muller does not
agree with bars conclusions and that
Barre knew that Muller does not agree
with bars conclusions try to follow that
here's what the letter actually says
from special counsel Bob Muller the
summary letter the Department sent to
Congress and released to the public late
in the afternoon of March 24th did not
fully capture concern capture the
concern the context nature and substance
of this office's work and conclusions
there is now public confusion about
critical aspects of the result of our
investigation this threatens to
undermine a central purpose for which
the department appointed the special
counsel to assure full public confidence
in the outcome of the investigations
again
to begin who cares what Bob Muller
thinks about the release or the context
or whatever what matters is is the
Attorney General accurately relating the
report but who cares what Muller thinks
about the context or how many press
conferences bar should do bill bill bar
does not answer to Bob Muller the
special counsel is not the Attorney
General the Attorney General does not
report to the special counsel the
special counsel reports to the DOJ to
the Attorney General
ultimately the only question that
matters here is the accuracy of the
context or the summaries or whatever now
the question is ambiguous right the
letter says that bill bars letter did
not fully capture the context who cares
the nature may be that matters and the
substance definitely may be that matters
of the offices work in conclusions three
things context nature substance
if bill bar didn't provide the context
that bob muller wanted doesn't matter if
bill barr inaccurately presented or
relayed the nature of the investigation
and conclusions maybe that does matter
what does what does Mulder mean by
nature here talking about the facts or
is he talking about some ambiguous term
in the substance this is the one that
really might matter if he is accusing
William Barr of misrepresenting the
substance of his conclusions that's a
very serious criticism but did Muller is
that what mother means Mulder is using
pretty ambiguous terminology here well
Billboard was asked this question today
he gives a very straight answer the
opportunity to review that letter before
it went out and he declined on Thursday
morning I received it probably was
received at the department Wednesday
night or evening but on Thursday morning
I received a letter from Bob the letter
that's just been put into the record and
I called Bob and said you know what's
the issue here
are you sick and I asked him if he was
suggesting that the March 24th letter
was inaccurate and he said no but that
the press reporting had been inaccurate
and that the press was reading too much
into it and I asked him you know
specifically what his concern was and he
said that his concern focused on his
explanation of why he did not reach a
conclusion on obstruction and he wanted
more put out on that issue he wanted he
argued for putting out summaries of each
volume the executive summaries that had
been written by his office and if not
that than other material that focused on
the issue of why he didn't reach the
obstruction question but he was very
clear with me that he was not suggesting
that we had misrepresented his report
there it is bill bar gets the letter
from Bob Muller
saying that bill bars letter to Congress
did not fully capture the concerns about
the context and the nature and the subs
didn't fully capture and so Bob Barr
call bill bar bill and Bob Billy Bob
Billy Bob Thornton bill bar calls Bob
Muller and says listen to bars very
precise language are you suggesting that
my letter to Congress did not accurately
portray what was in your report are you
suggesting that I was inaccurate
in how I talked to Congress and Muller
said no no no I'm not suggesting you
were inaccurate I'm suggesting that I
want you to release more context more
summaries more executive summaries of
the report because in the Muller report
you have about 400 pages 380 something
like that and before each volume two
volumes you have an executive summary
now the executive summary was very
helpful when that report was released
and I had to go on TV in about 10
minutes and so I had to quickly scan the
executive summary but clearly what Bob
Muller wanted was for William Barr to
release that executive summary right
away and William Bar says no I'm not
going to release multiple summaries
especially staggered overtime that are
going to confuse people now it's not Bob
Muller's call on what summaries and how
many press conferences and how many
press interviews he wants to give it
seems from the leaking of Bob Muller's
letter that he or somebody on his team
is pretty familiar with talking to the
press but what William Barr said is no
we're not going to do that and here's
his reasoning why I told Bob that I was
not interested in putting out summaries
and I wasn't going to put out the report
piecemeal I wanted to get the whole
report
and I thought summaries by very
definition regardless of who prepared
them would be under-inclusive and we'd
have sort of a series of different
debates and public discord over each
tranche of information that went out and
I wanted to get everything out at once
and we should start working our paths
free sound reasoning and by the way it
turns out that Barr was right baris
argument is if you release these things
piecemeal and different summaries that's
going to be endlessly ripped apart
argued about there's going to be a lot
of controversy better to just give
Congress the quick view of things and
then release the report when we can and
by the way the only reason Barr had to
send that letter to Congress in the
first place which obviously then came
out to the public was because William
Barr asked Bob Muller to send him over a
report with the grand jury sections
highlighted so that it would be much
easier for the Department of Justice to
then go in and redact those areas
because you're not allowed to release
that grant grand jury information there
are multiple aspects of this report that
you legally cannot release to the public
so he said listen when you've got the
grand jury information just highlight it
so that it makes it easier for us to go
through it Muller sends over a four
hundred page report without any of those
annotations on it and so William Barr
can't just release the report he can't
just say okay well I did a quick
half-hour pass there you go here's four
hundred pages everybody he had to go
through it very meticulously as a matter
of law however because he had the report
he also wanted to be transparent and he
knew that the media and the public were
very interested in this report so rather
than wait weeks and weeks and and open
himself up to accusations and he was
changing the report he was doctoring it
he wouldn't let it be released he sent
out a four-page letter to Congress to
keep them apprised to what was going on
especially in their oversight role and
then he released the report as quickly
as possible we have the report you can
read the report you can see whether the
letter was accurate or inaccurate it was
accurate now this this
is the question how was the Muller
letter to bar released to the press
seems pretty clear to me seems pretty
clear to me that the Muller team is a
little leakier than we thought it was we
were told through the whole
investigation Mulder never leaks Muller
never leaks certainly appeared that way
but now I'm beginning to question that
and when chuck grassley the Republican
senator was questioning William bar bar
raised this point specifically what are
you doing to investigate unauthorized
media contacts by the department and FBI
officials during the Russian
investigation we have multiple criminal
leak investigations underway multiple
criminal leak investigations underway as
it should be all of this is theater you
can see the report you can read the
report so now the Democrats because they
have nothing on the actual question try
to vilify bar trouble for them this is
the best part of watching this hearing
this morning is that William bar is much
smarter than all of these people
combined here is Democrat Sheldon
Whitehouse trying to take a shot at bar
the entirety of your previous career in
the Department of Justice including as
Attorney General
have you ever referred to authorized
Department investigative activities
officially or publicly as spying I'm not
asking for private conversations I'm not
going to have juror the use of the word
spying I think you know my first job was
in CIA I don't think the word spying has
any pejorative connotation at all to
meet us to me the question is always
whether or not it's authorized and
adequately predicated spying
I think spying is a good English word
that in fact doesn't have synonyms
because it is the broadest word
incorporating really all forms of covert
intelligence collection so I'm not going
to back off the word spying to except I
will say when did you adjust thing any
pejorative and I use it frequently as
you media oh it's just devastating it's
so bad and obviously it's bad because
William Bar uses very technical language
here
he used a sophisticated language he says
I'm not going to observe the term spying
because I don't think it carries a
pejorative but then he he even makes the
point clearer for the media and everyone
who's watching he says I think spying is
a good English word it has no synonyms
because it's the broadest word you can
use and this was a masterstroke nobody
is picking up on this but this was a
masterstroke for more than more reasons
than one the whole debate over the last
two years about Russia gate in the
investigation and the
counterintelligence investigation and
the criminal of it all this has
surrounded the question of the deep
state it has surrounded the question of
spying and what the Democrats have been
saying is the deep state the spying was
totally justified all the FISA
surveillance totally justified and what
the Republicans have been saying is this
was an abuse the spying was bad spying
is awful we shouldn't have people spying
on each other and the premise here of
the the White House Sheldon Whitehouse
is question the premise is that the
spying is bad so Sheldon Whitehouse
without even realizing it he's accepting
the conservative premise yeah of course
it's bad to spy on your political
opponents yeah of course of course if
there was spying it's really bad that's
why we can't use the word spy that's why
we've got to make up some new word and
and we have to get rid of the word
spying what Barr is pointing out here is
that the Democrat Sheldon Whitehouse is
accepting the Republican premise saying
senator Whitehouse you're using the word
spying as though it's a bad thing I used
to work at the CIA our government spies
all the time spying is a neither good
nor bad spying is a totally morally
neutral term the question is whether the
spying was legal legitimate appropriate
or whether what it was inappropriate
whether it was an abuse of power Sheldon
Whitehouse gives up the whole game here
he's saying oh and yeah of course this
spying is bad no no I'm not using the
spying in a bad way you're using it in a
bad way why because you know that the
spying that took place you know that the
FISA warrants from the Trump campaign
based on nothing
based on democrat funded steal dossiers
and Russian disinformation you know that
that spying was bad you know that it
carries a pejorative connotation it's a
subtle point it's not going to be widely
appreciated but that point is going to
matter in the coming weeks so he fails
he fails to take down bar Dianne
Feinstein also tries to take her shot at
barb you still have a situation where a
president essentially tries to change
the lawyers account in order to prevent
further criticism of himself well that's
not a crime and she she just sort of
spammers after that cuz uh she's got
nothing there's an interesting point on
language here as well which is you hear
the Democrats trying to use all of this
confusing jargony terminology trying to
imply that certain activities like the
relationship with the lawyers and to the
clients and the then that this is
somehow nefarious and then bill bar
comes in very clearly he goes that's not
a crime what crime are you alleging I
wish bill Barr had been around two years
ago the Donald Trump colluded with the
Russians there's no evidence that he did
even if he did collusion is not a crime
there's no crime of collusion he is yet
bill Barr is just the absolute BS
destroyer he just decimates it with that
totally blase look on his face he looks
like a bored bulldog he does remind me
in many ways of Scalia when you would
see Scalia
rip apart bad arguments he would do it
with this kind of blase well the problem
with your argument is it's completely
wrong that's what Bill Barr is doing
here and they have no answer you you
concede
and Feinstein just stammered how many
homina homina what's the real reason at
the end of all of this circus
the Democrats want bar out right now
what's the real reason he's a bulldog
now maybe they're just desperate they're
grasping at straws they need a new
boogeyman sure I think there's a more
material reason to and it's William bars
answer to this question from Lindsey
Graham do you share my concerns about
the FISA warrant process yes
do you share my concerns about the
counterintelligence investigation how
was opened and why it was opened yes you
share my concerns that the professional
lack of professionalism and the Clinton
email investigations something we should
all look at yes yes indeed
the investigators become the
investigated and the real injustice that
took place over the last two years might
soon be exposed because you've got this
bulldog this highly intelligent highly
professional highly trained bulldog now
turning the tables on the entire Russia
narrative so much more to get to we'll
have to do it tomorrow so much to look
forward to get your mailbag questions in
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael NOLA I'll see them
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkiss and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jeshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright day
Lee Weyer 2019 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know vladimir putin may be a
world-class al capone but he's done us a
big favor in venezuela he's putting on a
video exhibition about why socialism is
bad why gun rights are good and why
Donald Trump and his team of foreign
policy tough guys may be the men of the
hour
I'm Andrew Clavin that's on the Andrew
Clavin show